at your Peak uh when like you were I
don't know uh lifting a [ __ ] ton and I
guess you because I don't know
completely like what gear you you may
have taken what do you think was there
ever a moment where like emotionally
like you were so fired up that maybe you
thought like oh [ __ ] this is kind of
like a lot like as a person
um any time I took Trent in the past I
would get very
very unjustifiably paranoid oh
interesting yeah what just anything for
example and you're you're in a
relationship with a girl and
everything's fine but in your head
you're like she's cheating on me for
sure oh interesting that's a weird [ __ ]
interesting yeah or just something
random I'm you know today something bad
is gonna happen to me of this impending
paranoia of just a nonsensical outcome
that normally you would not even think
about that's crazy yeah it does weird
stuff to your brain yeah yeah yeah there
was a dude uh that I kind of talked to
on Twitter I don't know if he's taking
Trent anymore when he was taking Trend
he started this thread of like psycho
dreams he was having and it made me I
was like damn that'd be a just a really
dope short film just like a 10 or 15
minute thing of like a dude taking Trend
and then every time he closes his eyes
he like goes into some crazy ass moment
that's like 30 seconds to a minute
there's something called Trend sweats
too where when you're on Trend
specifically you you wake up and you're
just soaked in sweat oh wow yeah dude
this [ __ ] fascinates me yeah
have you seen yeah I've heard of Trent
coffee yeah what is that say you you
inject it and if you're unlucky it's
like a roll of the dice every time you
pin it but when you when you pin it
there's like depending on a bunch of
different factors but I think it's more
so it leaking into I don't know the way
it gets into circulation sometimes the
the drug itself your body has a reaction
where it tries to kind of like cough it
out whoa and it's weird because it's I
don't know if it's in just the drug
specifically or if it's also has to do
with the carrier oils and the solvents
that you use specifically to suspend the
trend it's more of like a chemistry
thing yeah but this drug in general is
more prevalently associated with having
a coughing fit after pinning it so you
could be in the bathroom you shoot it
and then you're kind of just praying to
God that you don't end up having the
coughing fit but then you if you feel it
coming on you know for the next four
minutes you're going through hell and
you just sit there and you're looking at
the mirror preparing yourself and you
just hack up a lung for like four
minutes straight
and there's no other more sobering
moment of why the [ __ ] am I doing this
to myself yeah you're just some yoked
out of your tree bodybuilder looking at
yourself just cough to [ __ ] death in
front of yourself in the mirror yeah so
I take I know bodybuilders who literally
they're like [ __ ] and then I get into
the fetal position on the ground and
they just cough for three minutes
straight that is oh my God oh my God
yeah let's do it that's yeah I want a
filter right now yeah when I need to
feel it when I was on Zach's podcast the
other day we were talking about how I
think it's the equivalent of like
post-nut Clarity but steroid Edition
yeah it's like you watch you watch some
[ __ ] up porn and you jerk off you're
like oh I'm a piece of [ __ ] after you're
done yeah like what am I doing I'm
disgusting but with Trent it's like the
same thing you pin it you start to get
the cough come on and you're watching
yourself just you can't control it at
all just succumb to this [ __ ] yeah
brutal cough it's over yeah and you're
just like what am I doing with my life
was this even worth it that kind of
reminds me of like this like video from
I think like some Irish bodybuilder and
it's I think it's titled what it takes
to get stage lean maybe you've seen it
it was pretty I'd say it went pretty
viral and he does like this six minute
thing he's like being stage Lane it's
not worth it and he just like goes
through this whole [ __ ] thing right
he's talking about how his life sucks
he's like your relationship with food
it's terrible like he just he makes it
sound so bad but then at the end he's
like
but I'm not gonna lie like I like
looking like this so I'm just gonna keep
being [ __ ] ripped as [ __ ] yeah
what's the most [ __ ] up cycle that
you've been on like just was it Trend or
was it like what were the symptoms I'm
not tuning you guys out I'm just I want
to try to find this dude yeah it's fine
I just did that too because I wanted to
ask you about another bodybuilder that I
was I don't know on his page recently
hit it probably the most I've ever used
was Test Plus Trend plus something
called Master on and then I think I
threw in orals on top of that I might
have used Winstrol it was a while ago so
I forget exactly but test Tran masteron
was like the main biggest stack I would
say and just because you wanted to be as
big as possible yeah well that's the
thing is when there's less knowledge on
the internet too unless people educating
about the realities of the stuff you
would often go by just underground
knowledge through gyms and your your
Bros in the gym and what they say is
correct or forums where a lot of this
like lore around what you're supposed to
do or not do would kind of circulate and
go down trickle down the Grapevine but
there was less of an emphasis on like
science or I don't know just things that
have anecdotally worked over the years
and we used to think or at least you
know back in the day one of the things
you would get the impression of is you
needed to take a [ __ ] ton of stuff to
when you're cutting to look a certain
way but what you find out after a while
is a lot of this stuff basically at a
certain point you can only hold your
muscle when you're cutting anyways
you're not trying to build typically
when you're eating in a deficit even if
you're on gear if you're experienced
enough you're not gonna gain a ton of
size when you're cutting down so you're
just trying to preserve what you have
essentially like the goal is to lose all
the fat but keep all the muscle
essentially so there's only so much you
need to actually do that and then once
you go above and beyond that you're kind
of just using drugs for no reason like
more and yeah back then it was like you
know I could have gotten away with a
third or a quarter of the [ __ ] probably
and had the same outcome wow yeah and is
that one of the reasons why you're so
like honest about this is just yeah it
was like things that I wish I knew when
I started and just providing like
further information so that guys don't
like get themselves and yeah or they
know the realities of what they're
getting themselves into yeah because
back in the day it was you know you you
would have somebody in high schools be
like here's a ball of d-ball bro it's
[ __ ] took yeah and then let's go
drinking after yeah yeah which which
what that'll [ __ ] you up drinking plus
people yeah yeah they're both liver
toxic oh okay yeah yeah and it's just
not can do like if you're gonna expose
yourself to these drugs like you should
probably make the most of it while
you're on it not go drinking and you
know be a dumbass and yeah like [ __ ]
yeah yeah I mean it is so wild well two
things one watching your videos help me
just accept like all right genetically I
got a cap like I can only get so much
and that's fine but two to the point of
like high schoolers and stuff doing
roids and like like you know what you
wish you knew it's still so wild to me
like when sarms got really popular yeah
it was like this crazy Wildfire of
teenagers like all it takes is one
teenager to be like yeah I'm trying them
out and then a bunch of teenagers go and
do it and it's like even
the delay in time where like maybe a
dude like yourself can get on Tick Tock
to be like no don't take that [ __ ] that
could be really [ __ ] up for you it's
like at that point
with how rapid social media is now it's
like damn there's however many kids
already took who knows how many like
doses of sarms before they got to that
still like yeah tick tock's been really
bad about like I don't know it's weird
because they'll they'll ban stuff that's
I would say doesn't need to be banned
but then leave [ __ ] up that makes no
sense to be up yeah like underage girls
or like whatever [ __ ] about sarms and
it's it's so bite-sized that the only
thing you can really extrapolate out
from a video of some teen on sarms or
something is him saying showing his
physique and saying what he's doing and
there's no education or harm reduction
or any warning or anything and it's it's
pretty problematic for sure yeah what do
you think about Nick Walker
[ __ ] huge I mean he's like the
biggest dude I've ever seen in my entire
life yeah yeah he's insane he's the
mutant yeah like I just I this dude is
he looks like crang from [ __ ] Ninja
Turtles dude yeah I I mean like I I
don't know I I just I read so much about
like bodybuilders dying of heart attacks
um and then I fell onto this guy's page
and I was like Jesus Christ like how
what are you sacrificing you know dude
this is how I feel after I [ __ ]
penley wrote no the 80 pounds this is
also I don't think recent go to his
Instagram he's way bigger than this no
how he's about to go at the Olympian
like a few days yeah really so yeah so
he probably looks absolutely nonsensical
right now he is huge dude look at his
leg he would go back
look at his leg what size shoe does he
wear do you think I think he's our
height he's five nine you're at it I
swear to God he's five nine so if he's
got like a size 10 shoe on it's not like
when you get more jacked your foot girls
I'm just I I like it's a size 22 foot I
try to think of things like in scale
like if he wears like a size 10 shoe
right that's about your shoe size right
there and so like in my mind I mentally
try to compare how [ __ ] massive of
his size compared to his shoe dude